los ataques aéreos de israel sobre gaza
y el lanzamiento de cohetes desde la
franja se han extendido a una segunda
jornada sin cese durante esta madrugada
desde el enclave no todos los cohetes
pertenecerían a yihad islámica palestina
puesto que algunas facciones como las
brigadas de los mártires de al-aqsa se
han atribuido a algunos de los disparos
en su mayoría estos cohetes son
interceptados por la defensa antiaérea
israelí o caen en zonas despobladas lo
que no quita que las sirenas hayan
seguido sonando en el sur y el centro de
israel en contrapartida los bombardeos
del ejército israelí que son mediante
drones y aviones de combate si han
impactado en presuntos objetivos
terroristas siendo la zona de jan yunís
al sur de gaza una de las más afectadas
según las autoridades de salud locales
dos palestinos murieron en esta agresión
que se suman a las diez víctimas de este
viernes en paralelo destacamos que las
fuerzas de israel han proseguido sus
redadas en cisjordania ocupada y
detuvieron a otros 19 miembros de la
yihad islámica palestina en este
contexto no hay indicios de una
desescalada
al contrario el vocero de las fuerzas de
defensa israelíes dijo que la llamada
'operación despertar del alba podría
durar una semana mientras la jihad
sostiene que ahora es tiempo de
resistencia no de tregua algo que
difiere con la postura actual del grupo
hamas que aún mantiene conversaciones
con egipto para lograr un alto el fuego
sobre el terreno en gaza- la única
planta de energía se quedaría hoy sin
combustible debido al bloqueo de israel
que ya alcanza el quinto día generando
así que el suministro eléctrico se vea
reducido sólo a cuatro horas por día
además según reuters la mayoría de las
tiendas están cerradas y una vecina del
centro de gaza denunció que a diferencia
de otras ofensivas israelíes en esta
ocasión no hubo advertencias previas de
ataques para permitir la evacuación de
civiles